AER along the end line forward for Neils list in
front of the Dallas bench chipped forward it's
Wyatt Johnston in the center position as carried
back in by Vegas maruso in front and aure got the
blocker save as he stayed with Chandler Stevenson
scored two goals in their first three games this
season he hasn't scored since but the Stars on
Entry burp It Up In transition Stevenson gets
fed by marol a great opportunity there thwarted
by AER can't turn Puck over at the two blue lines
here today white cloud from distance that off of
uner and then bounced to Stevenson and he scored
that one he was denied on the earlier look it
fell right to him and it's the golden knights
tantalizing stop by Jake ainger on that but
they can't get regrouped in out of Their Own
Zone and this time it's fatal little cycle down
low Stevenson gives it up goes to the weak side
front of the net gets it off the N of humanity
a very fortuitous bounce off of the bodies in
front Jake gets bumped by his own and in the
corner good work Johnston for Robertson curs
behind the net Banks it up high for Harley back
for Robertson his shot a tip save Thompson and
coming in was lanquist couldn't find the puck the
Stars though hold it in lanquist T shot blocked by
Hunton Dallas digs for it in the attack Zone it's
tied to landria switch of directions on heg sharp
angle and Thompson had the post hug the shot
from Smith Lindell wraps it back in deep Greg
Smith worked by hey the big body going flying
was delandria on contact W the other way for
the knights they've got a trailer White Cloud
he's shot he's scored slid one underneath AER
White Cloud scored his first goal of the season in
their last game on Wednesday the Stars got chasing
back into their own Zone and outnumbered into
the defensive end it's just a straightforward
shot by a shot blocking defenseman does it Clank
off the Stick of anybody as it goes five hole
like a wet bar of soap just a little cin drag
I think Jake Ginger was probably anticipating
something else hand off for Stevenson he's got
maraso Jamie Ben intercepts now hackin paaw
back for Ben here comes the Dallas Captain
cross the line snaps a shot save rebound
score right off the glove of Logan Thompson
and of Guinea to dunov this week it's all
coming against his former team transition good
defense and hustle to get back and reload Jamie
shot beguiled the glove hand of Thompson a rebound
he shouldn't have given up but look at the Trot
to the net by the stars both steel and dadonov
drive to the net and the former golden Knight
of Genny did on off able to chip one home Far
Side Marchman red hot goal scorer five in his
last five pelski a one-time save made rebound
crashing the net was marchment after duain had
put it there nearly picked off by Robertson
cleared by the knights 45 left on the power
play a lethal looking two-on-one short-handed
that was the best look either side in that two
minutes L down by Stone he's got eel charges
ahead barbashev for stone shot block re bounce
scored Harley blocked the initial chance Stone
the followup the bounce went right to the golden
knights they score their third of this opening
period they're so good at making plays on entry
and buying a little bit of space and stars have
players back but they're able to find a gap it's
one of those lurchy broken plays where the shot
is blocked the players are looking for it the goal
tend can't adjust to it Jake bit hard on the
initial shot and after it rattled around was
in hinp slides it over Harley for Johnston pass
tipped on net Robertson able to redirect it and
Thompson in his crease made the stand a glacial
Pace on the business end of it though they go
high to low as they call it blue line down deep
into the now dadonov tended for Johnston stolen
and back up the knights it's Howen left Circle
cutting in and the paddle down by AER didn't
allow the move he stopped it covered left wing
side and AER just stuffs him essentially gets the
paddle down on the ice you're not going to get
out in front uses the post as an anchor that's
a tough play for Meo hkin he did well to not take
a penalty on it it's like the golden knights have
approached this second period like a boxer has
just got his gloves up protecting his head steel
Works in fed to the slot follows up and just
fought off by Thompson it was a broken play
great look by Steel just kind of out of nothing
the STS able to stretch and then the Swift move
to the interior got the golden knights and
basically the ey formation in their own Zone
and against the grain just above the blocker I
think it caught the arm arm Kar is out of the
box the Stars 0 for two on the power play kri a
behind the net wrap around and oer made the save
chip by W Harley gets there takes the check from
W Fox up his pass can't be cleared Stone got it
to W he scores Mark Stone kept that puck in in
front of the Blue Line a great defensive play
he sets up W and the golden knights have their
biggest lead what he does he's one of the best
at that they install the puck down deep in the
zone stars have to hustle back under four check
pressure looks as though they're going to get out
no problem instead the pass in the mid middle by
foxa intended for tied to landrea just gets
gobbled up he's great at reading plays like
that they slide it down and a wrist shot from
another light scorer three goals in the first
six games for w zero cents so he joins Stevenson
andelle hustled couldn't get there in time to keep
so the stars have to touch back up they turn over
possession as they do Paul conter through Center
Ice into the star Zone they say on side conter
shoots wide Rebound in front and dorv scores
wasn't on side as they entered 21 into the third
period the golden knights tack on another and
then a nice shift to the forehand initially the
stars and Jake ainger just swimming defensively
in the aftermath of the Miss they have lots of
energy they haven't played since Wednesday shot
by duain is sticks stick aside by to darting
down the right side he and lanquist go hard
into the boards tumble their way down the loose
Puck kept in by the night it's Conor a backand he
scores he pulls the monkey off his back as
the golden knights get their sixth goal in
the game from their sixth different player
golden knights who have not scored in eons
that finds the back of it of the net cter
hasn't scored since Halloween stars can't
get it out of the Zone they're sluggish getting
back to the net Jake bites hard on the first
move from Carter who pulls the monkey off his
back after he just goes to the back end and
plops one past the glove of a bager Jake ainger
pick things back up on Monday night against the
Detroit Red Wings you can find reasons for
the leak in this one here today but they're
giving up too many goals lately that has
to get severed and cauterized immediately